vous pouvez vous souvenir de ce que cela signifie allez ok
bravo comment allez-vous
[Musique]
ce n'est pas facile à apprendre il n'y a pas
de manuels donc
mes collègues ont dû apprendre de manière assez ad
hoc maintenant les nouveaux professeurs ont un
programme plus structuré  à suivre c'est très
similaire au français son héritage est le
français normand mais il a ses propres
orthographes, mots et grammaire et ce
n'est pas si facile à apprendre donc ça prend du
temps
[Musique]
nous sommes la dernière génération
mon frère
et tous mes collègues  étaient la dernière
génération à le parler naturellement
c'est le plus triste
maintenant
oui nous avons maintenant de jeunes professeurs et
des jeunes qui l'ont appris et ont été
capables de le parler assez bien
[Musique]
c'est incroyablement important bien qu'aucune
culture ne soit complète sans sa
langue  et euh il n'y a aucun moyen de
vraiment comprendre l'esprit de jersey
sans comprendre sa langue euh
et si jerry a meurt alors jersey
deviendra juste une autre partie de la bretagne et
ce sera incroyablement triste
[Musique]
toi